bonsoir
je suis
avis togolais comme les dix écrivains
p
''j'étais doré à forcier dame emma
106ème l'homme d'acier animé à nyon
kelly amyot a adoré domaine
quand j'étais enfant ma grand-mère était
vendeuse de produits maraîchers les
tuent au nom carottes au tout ça donc la
ramenait souvent la maison
du coup on avait beaucoup de restes et
on faisait un devoir de la sellette des
salades famille soit le mercredi et les
voiles et vendredi et on était un peu
connu dans le quartier visité un
quartier populaire comme ce qui faisait
se voir de la salade et pour ceux qui
connaissent un peu le mode de dire
élémentaire au togo la salade c'est un
peu la nourriture des riches on va dire
du coup on était assez content quand
même de changer régulièrement de la
salade est pour moi un radis d'un des
plus beaux souvenirs de mon enfance et
les repas en famille comme ça autour de
ce plage ou tout simplement que mais
quand même qui nous rendait assez unique
et qui nous réunit c'est ce qui est
dérangeant c'est qu'aujourd'hui ma grand
mère a pris sa retraite ya longtemps en
tant que vendeuse produits maraîchers et
ceux qui auront pris la relève de son
activité dire de produire sion 2-2
d'éléments et de moulay geoffrey c'est à
dire et marashi les ventes de l'été les
distributeurs ont des soucis à se faire
et aujourd'hui on nous faisait faire ma
grand mère elle bombe elle un peu le
tout ça aujourd'hui mais selon 10 à se
faire à cause des perturbations dans la
chaîne d'approvisionnement
climatique les saisons bref tout ce qui
nous réunit ici aujourd'hui et vous
poser la question comment expliquer à ma
grand mère aujourd'hui dans le confort
de sa retraite pourquoi ses collègues
d'aujourd'hui ont des problèmes et ou
ont des défis à relever comment je lui
explique les changements climatiques je
me suis dit que j'allais lui expliquer
mon endroit en tant qu'écrivain que ça
ça m'intrigue et elle expliqué en tant
que
national et lui expliquer ça dansait
mois m c'est à dire dans notre langue
maternelle les féminins
c'est là où j'ai été confronté au défi
au dilemme des e-bonds
changement climatique cominak moi je dis
je dis ça pour s'y connaissent un peu le
climat ça serait il y avait nommé
changement entre autres ça ferait trop
si c'est pas assez consistante qu'est ce
que ça dit à quoi ça renvoie est-ce
qu'on voit vraiment est-ce que ça va
même charge par exemple en france est de
dire climatique ou en anglais claridge
que de dire iam est nommé trottoir
donc j'ai poussé un peu la réflexion et
sélection frapper se retrouvaient du
brand content que en réalité derrière le
simple fait de la langue il y avait des
choses bien plus profonde que ça ça m'a
frappé de me rendre compte que nos
anciens nos ancêtres nos grands parents
ou de nos parents pour ce qui est des
plus vieux vivait arrêté dans un univers
ancré dans les cycles
climatiques d'ailleurs on suivait les
respirations du 2 du temps des saisons
et on avait arrêté en crète où le
langage mais là dedans par exemple
justement c'est pour ceux qui ne dormait
pas durant leurs cours dv et quantité
étaient sur les bancs s'étaient massés
facultative mais quand même
vous la chanson de l'e santé au début
vous là vous l'avez reconnu ce sont les
mois
dans notre langue donc je vais trouver
et et doré et c est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le nom en réalité
est moins élevé est ancré dans l'est
dans les cycles naturels
normaux je dirais de du climat pour
prendre un exemple ou ou désuets jsm
lampard est essentielle ça veut dire ses
choix enlèvement sèchement les voiries
et en étendre le linge et l'enlever
pourquoi que développe parce que la
période de juillet normalement et
marquez avait plus épisodique
intermittence et donc quand on séchait
le linge en tant que j'ai deux de
l'enlever assez régulièrement pareil
pour 17 mois d'août normalement à cette
période est marquée par celle où on
faisait l'huile de palme parce que la
récolte était fait et donc on met des
choses deviennent littéralement mettre
la met dans le mille donc voyez avec ces
petits éléments on voit comment en
réalité les anciens étaient ancrés dans
les cycles naturels de du climat pas
répond nos cousins par exemple nos
cousins fonds à côté 21e ou seul et je
rends compte que même eux par exemple le
mois de janvier correspondait au mois de
la sécheresse oui mars et la première
pluie de la nuit si c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui
outre l'émoi du froid oui et décembre
vous ce bas monde c'est moi c'est l'émoi
de l'harmattan c'est à dire que dans un
monde où le climat change
qu'est ce que ça veut dire d'avoir des
mots en réalité qui sont ancrées dans
l'ancienne réalité j'en veux dire et
donc cela m'a fait me rende compte que
nos anciens
avec déjà le sens du temps normal et
donc que dans la perte de 10 de matériel
linguistique en réalité il y à
l'évidence du fait climatique aidant
quand on pense depuis nos langues on
comprend mieux jamais dire l'ampleur du
du déficit net ce n'est pas seulement
une érosion côtière mais c'est ce que
j'appellerais une érosion culturelle
et donc cela appelle vraiment à
recentrer
nos réflexions autour de 2,2 l'an passé
à sa part de là en partant de là on
comprend
comment nos anciens je suis là tu
pensais cette catégorie là aujourd'hui
dans le contexte où on
emploie systématiquement l'aigle et
concepts d'autrui en dehors c'est la
date de truies comme dirait qu'ils et
comme il dit dans les hamacs d'autrui
c'est comme dormir par terre alors c'est
vrai que la chanson d'aujourd'hui dit
qu'on a c'est parti ça peut encore
tomber mais quand même il faut se poser
la question il faut se poser la question
de kent autres nhat hanh ou façade sur
ce radeau qu'elle aurait climatique et
comment on produit en réalité d'autres
catégories parce que dans un contexte où
on est a envahi par une nuée de mouches
changement climatique co2 ont parcouru
de résilience et tous ces mots en
réalité qui font joli mais qui nous
viennent souvent d'ailleurs et qui sont
un peu des papiers des débits bien
emballés dans de jolis papiers qu'un
cadeau mais quand on déballe ça ne veut
pas forcément dire la même chose pour
tout le monde veuille résilience par
exemple dans la langue de vos
grands-parents pu poser la question de
maternelle qu'est ce que ça veut dire
qu'est ce que cela implique
pour un continent qui participe aussi
peu finalement à la pollution en général
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ces mots là
quand on les questionne dans nos langues
et s'armer intellectuellement face à
l'avalanche de concepts qui tient
nombreuses souvent les concepts dîne
avec les subventions et les financements
et les ong qui veut reprendre sa ici
vous dites est obligé un peu de forme et
la chose dans des dents là dessus la
natte de truites et donc maîtriser nos
outils linguistiques
pensez un peu dans nos langues ou en
tout cas s'appuyer dessus parce que on
est immergé
eric et de l'histoire pour unia ne faut
pas se le cacher mais s'appuient
là-dessus vous permet de découvrir des
trésors de cultures de rapport au monde
le rapport aux cycles naturels qui
permettent de tenir ferme si on veut
faso aux dictats conceptuel d'abord et
puis financier idéologique qui est
d'ailleurs qu'est ce que ça veut dire de
demander de faire des efforts
pour le climat un peuple qui pour lui le
moins de co2 je suis la planète qu'est
ce que ça veut dire qu'est ce qu'est ce
que ça veut dire d'une part et de
résilience à nous et surtout à qui nous
adressons nous à qui va-t-on parler en
quelle langue on envoie le parler en
français en anglais c'est de passer
dépasse certains et donc se recentrer en
réalité sur à qui s'adresse ce qui lui
parlait dans sa gamme kiev noxolo
langanu en réalité le droit étranger à
ça ça permet de découvrir des trésors
comme jeudi de culture et ça nous permet
de penser de nos catégories proposées
nos points de vue et sauves et vont
sauver non seulement nos cadres de vie
mais également notre culture parce qu'il
ne s'agit pas uniquement de 2,2 deux
maisons de pib mais il s'agirait avant
de préserver ce qui est dû à des prix
mérite de l'être c'est-à-dire aussi nos
cultures et jeudi de se demander qu'est
ce que c'est par an dans une langue
comme libé autant ancré dans le cycle
naturel dans le contexte 11,6 en train
d'être complètement déstabilisée et donc
proposons notre vision du monde
maintenant les chaussons de ce souci
s'il le faut et un boson également aux
autres notre vision depuis la housse
tout ça j'ai découvert un peu en tirant
le fil de quoi d'expliquer le défi
climatique talabot de ma grand mère sur
ce je vous dis vive l'afrique et merci à
vous